welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Marvel's secret invasion is
teaching us that you cannot trust
anything including that the show's
opening titles were designed by a human
the opening scene of the series reveals
that agent Everett Ross is a scroll
imposter but for how long has this been
the case was the abducted and replaced
recently or has he been a scroll the
whole time the whole time though the
whole time you would fight the whole
time this question really gets to the
heart of how we should question all MCU
characters as we return to this search
and I have devised a helpful scroll
checklist that we can run all Marvel
faces through to determine just how
scroll suspicious they are hey new
rockstars is now three channels this
main channel for Easter egg breakdowns
the break room which is the new home of
our inside Marvel secret Invasion after
shows and the Deep dive for some special
film analyzes from me subscribe to all
three and support us with a squirrel
inspired shirt at nerd riot.shop okay to
determine how long someone might have
been a scroll you really have to look at
their full known MCU timeline Everett
Ross first appeared as a CIA agent
detaining the Winter Soldier and the
joint countertop terrorist Center in
Berlin in Captain America Civil War he
returned in Black Panther running into
t'challa in a casino in Seoul and then
joined them back in wakanda he returned
and black panther wakanda forever
jogging in Virginia and helping the
wakandans commit Espionage betraying his
ex-wife CIA director Val and landing in
federal custody where Okoye broken free
so he has been on the Run since then a
man without a country Nick Fury and
Maria Hill formerly occupied that
fugitive status after Captain America
the Winter Soldier but came back into
the fold after the events of infinity
war and end game and now Nick Fury
oversees saber with the consent of the
U.S president so as of episode 1 of
secret Invasion we do not know if Ross
was taken by the squirrels after Okoye
freed him or if he had been a squirrel
long before that this Ross in secret
Invasion Episode 1 has all the knowledge
and memories that this CIA agent would
have knowing that Nick Fury was on saber
so either Ross was a squirrel for a long
time or it was a recent switch and the
squirrels just took Ross's memories one
would think it would be hard for
squirrels to get their hands on Ross if
he was with the wakandans but we also
don't know if Ross stayed with Okoye and
we don't know that the squirrels haven't
also infiltrated wakanda notice how when
Ross calls Maria Hill for an extraction
his name shows up on her car's computer
so this scrolled version of Ross has
been associating with Hill for quite
some time like she probably knew he was
meeting with Prescott they had been
working together here we actually asked
secret Invasion director Ali Saleem
about whether these episodes were real
how far back Martin Freeman's Everett
Ross has been a scroll in the MCU here
was his answer is the Everett Ross in
the opening episode
has he been a scroll the whole time is
there at Everett Ross cooling somewhere
in a freezer just hanging out or is he
on vacation I think all will be revealed
if all will be revealed is how my uncle
signs off all of his emails oh really a
little ominous yeah yeah I might steal
it typically for bigger named guest
stars in these MCU Disney Plus shows
they appear in at least two episodes
Julia louis-dreyface shot scenes for two
different episodes of the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier visited an operio shot
scenes for two episodes of Hawkeye
though his scenes with young Echo were
cut I think we will see Martin Freeman
again and I would just be surprised if
we found out that he'd been scroll from
the very beginning why well Everett Ross
does fit the bill of what I'm calling
our scroll checklist someone who could
have been a scroll for some duration of
time that we've known them in the MCU
but he does fall short of one I think
it'd be helpful to run through this
whole checklist to look at all
characters through so Scrolls suspects
must be still alive like if we saw the
character die in their corpse stayed
human they obviously weren't a scroll so
Tony Stark Natasha Romanov Aunt May
t'challa they must be visibly human so
like no Androids like Vision or alien
races of other kinds like the Guardians
of the Galaxy we already know Rocket's
origin and we know Groot and Gamora are
already weird aliens so making them also
skrulls would just be kind of a step
down from the coolness that they already
are it'd be kind of a hat on a hat
there's a certain joy in building
something but let's be honest I'm not
gonna fire up my table saw and churn out
a birdhouse anytime soon I'm not really
The Rustic type but an Infinity Gauntlet
that's more my speed fan home is a brand
dedicated to developing unique
Collections and build up models from
Brands like Marvel and Star Wars with a
fan home subscription not only will you
get magazines about your favorite fandom
you'll also get all the pieces you need
to build your very own replica Infinity
Gauntlet the fan home replica Infinity
Gauntlet is officially licensed by
Marvel every month you'll get new parts
to add to your model as well as an
exclusive magazine detailing the secrets
of the infinity Saga each issue also
comes with detailed easy to follow
assembly instructions everything you
need to build your Gauntlet the new
Rockstar screw has been having fun
assembling The Gauntlet in the office
the full-size gauntlet stands at 28.7
inches tall and has LED light effects so
that the Infinity Stones light up when
you press them if you subscribe to Fan
home before June 30th you'll also get a
1-6 scale model of Iron Man's Gauntlet
to add to your collection a fan home
subscription is the perfect way to make
your collection stand out to get started
just click the link in the description
below also no bloody injuries so wind
Scrolls have a limb or a digit severed
or they bleed out profusely from
lacerations that's severed tissue in
blood is supposed to revert to squirrel
tissue in human blood so keep that one
in mind also no powers squirrels are
naturally stronger than normal humans
and they can replicate physical
appearances in the memories of someone
but not yet superpowers because that
would make them super Scrolls and this
series is already hinting at a scroll
plot to do that which is a new
initiative they're working on not
something that they've already had so I
don't think there would be past Super
Scrolls existing in the MCU so that
would count out Hulk Steve Rogers
kamalacan Thor wanna maximoff Etc also
they must be immune to radiation this is
established in episode one squirrels are
not affected by harmful radiation so if
someone has ever been sunburned
or affected by the cosmic radiation of
the Infinity Stones they're not a scroll
so Monica Rambo she was affected by the
cmbr of the hex so she is not a scroll
also the character must be known for
deceit I think for someone to be a
scroll they should have some kind of
known history for dishonesty or ulterior
motives the honest and transparent types
like Scott Lang like Jimmy woo the loyal
lieutenants like Okoye they're probably
not skrulls and lastly perhaps most
importantly they gotta be somewhat blank
slates and by this I mean characters for
whom revealing them as Scrolls wouldn't
controversially erase qualities that we
already like about them or cheap in
their Journeys like the less we know
about a character and the quirkier they
generally are the more likely Marvel
will feel okay revealing them as a
scroll for example it might be pretty
odd for Marvel to establish Elena Bulova
as being a scroll her entire life
because we saw her childhood we know
about her adolescents in the Red Room
having been brainwashed and we saw when
she transitioned through the blip and
for Elena not to have briefly reverted
to her scroll form in that private
bathroom would have just been kind of
weird so with this checklist list in
mind here are the top eight candidates
for past known MCU characters likely to
be confirmed as Scrolls in the series
Everett Ross he checks all the boxes but
he was seriously incapacitated during
the Black Panther film so I think back
then at least he was human but that
sometime after his Escape during wakanda
forever he was captured and he was
turned because yes other than that he
does check all the boxes okay next his
ex-wife Val I am 99 sure that Val is a
scroll she checks all the boxes she has
a purple streak in her hair she's shady
as hell she might be the highest profile
US government official who is a scroll
and Samuel L Jackson said that Julie
Louis Dreyfus sat behind him at the
Oscars poking him and saying we're gonna
fight we're gonna fight I can drop you
like a bag of Dirks next Sharon Carter
she's also a solid scroll candidate
she's another government spy she popped
out of nowhere she took some shady turns
to the fact of the Winter Soldier that
we're all still asking questions about
the problem with Sharon is she uses a
black widow style face cloaking mask in
that show's finale why would she need
that if she could shave shift okay next
option Laura Barton another other MCU
spy with more questions than answers
about her backstory She was recently
revealed as Mockingbird an agent of
shield in Hawkeye that would pose some
questions about their kids though now
Roadie is the likeliest scroll Avenger
the only issue with Roadie is he took a
nasty fall in Civil War and I think that
would have outed himself before also it
would suck to learn the Roadie who
fought alongside the Avengers in
Infinity war and in game was a scroll
but we still have a lot more to learn
about rhodey's relationship with the
Scrolls in episode two three four five
and six of this series let's talk about
happy Hogan I've always made a case for
this guy just because Jon Favreau always
seems game to help a Disney plus title
he's someone in the Tony Stark orbit
who's been there since 2008 I don't
think it would hurt us that much to find
out that he was a scroll but he was also
incapacitated after that bombing in Iron
Man 3. I also don't think a scroll would
expose themselves to so much legal
trouble in Spider-Man no way home but
someone else in Tony Stark's orbit from
that very first movie William ginteriva
kind of a nobody remember this guy was
part of Team Mysterio and Spider-Man far
from home I actually just discussed this
with Tim Gettys in the collab I just did
on kind of funny but team Mysterio
created the fake news Frenzy that agent
Prescott referred to this episode that
the scrolls are now directly benefiting
from he was a Stark Industries employee
and he turned into an illusion
technician who released Mysterio's
doctored video to the Press I think
there's a chance that one member of Team
Mysterio was a scroll and if so he's at
the top of it but one final candidate I
thought it was interesting how this
episode established that squirrels take
humans faces and their minds including
their memories that would mean that
someone who's an expert at some learned
behavior over the course of their lives
would be a victim to those skill sets
being hijacked and technically
practitioners of the Mystic Arts in the
MCU fall in that category Benjamin
Bratt's character and Doctor Strange in
the first movie proved that anybody can
learn it so I proposed to you that the
possibility that Wong is a scroll he's
the most frequent Cameo maker in Marvel
phase four he's someone who brings
comedic relief and I don't think would
take anything away from him being
sorcerer Supreme he's already a weirdo
and we already have extraterrestrial
Sorcerers in the MCU so let me know your
thoughts about this scroll search and
we'll check back in throughout the
series subscribe to all three of our
channels new rockstars the break room
and the deep dive and support us by
grabbing some merch at nerdrive.shop you
can follow me on Instagram and Twitter
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign